hi this is dr gregory sadler
i'm a professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years
and i find that many people run into
difficulties reading classic
philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos
each of them focused on one core concept
from an important philosophical text
i hope you find it useful as well
genius was a term that was much
thrown around in the 19th century
it didn't go away and we still use it
today in the 21st century and there were
a lot of uses
of it in the 20th century as well
and when we ask ourself well what is
genius we usually associate it with
people who are unusually productive
and their productions are of high value
can't be predicted ahead of time
we extend it not just to say artistic
production but to
organization of political communities or
especially these days we talk about
thought leaders
with their brilliant books and ted talks
or we talk about you know what used to
be called
captains of industry and now we call
them innovators
and you know tech moguls and things like
that and there's this whole conception
that there are all these
geniuses out there and they're somehow
you know
bigger brains or whatever we want to
call them they have an immense talent
compared to the rest of us and mill has
a somewhat
different take on genius that says okay
that's all
maybe true but that's just part of what
makes genius
valuable and he tells us something
that's a bit
paradoxical which is that for all of the
hype
and all of the you know textbook
uh praise of people of genius
that in a lot of ways we don't really
like genius
we see it as something that we're at
best indifferent to
and perhaps don't even want to have
around it's sort of like
not in my backyard sort of thing we have
this acronym
nimby for people who are all for cool
stuff just don't put it in my backyard
put it in somebody else's
backyard and so he tells us that um
uh i'm insist on the importance of
genius
and the necessity of allowing it to
unfold itself freely
both in thought and in practice being
well aware
no one will deny the position in theory
right everybody's four geniuses you know
if we do something that we want to say
would be
problematic so what if this this
canceled out an einstein
what if this stood in the way of
innovators right
everybody's for that in theory according
to mill
but it's a little bit different as he
says when it comes to
reality or practice he says
knowing almost no almost everyone in
reality
is totally indifferent to it people
think genius is a fine thing
if it enables a man to write an exciting
poem
or paint a picture or you know we might
say make an electric
car or shoot a rocket somewhere or
pick whatever you want you know organize
a new political strategy
that's all great but how do we really
feel about it he says nearly all at
heart
think they can do very well without it
we don't need
geniuses coming in here and upsetting
the proverbial apple cart
you know making waves as we say
rocking the boat think about all these
cliches right these cliches
are examples of something that might
have been the product of genius at one
time but we all use them
and we're really happy with that we like
things to be nice
and even when we want change as mill
says in another place
we often don't want it because it's
progress we just want change
for changes sake and so there's there's
a real risk of
wanting genius and recognizing genius
but not
for the right reasons we're often
indifferent
to true genius and what is what is
really
genius about what is its foundation
is it that they are these mysterious
figures and then out of the black box
that is this person as we see in movies
all the time
something happens and they produce this
amazing thing
i'm reminded of detective geniusing
for example in the show death in
paradise
it uses the traditional trope which we
see so often
also used in medical shows like for
example house
where you have the genius the eccentric
unpredictable person in the case of
death in paradise
it's nearly always a
white british person who comes in to the
island of sant marie
and you know is the di the detective
inspector in house
it's this uh you know diagnostician
who's kind of a curmudgeon
but what happens you know the they they
are the ones who can take in all the
information
and then some sudden flight of
inspiration comes
and they you know realize the pattern
that they've been missing
they bring everybody in so we can do
some exposition
and you know walk them through it kind
of sherlock holmes style
right and now is that how genius
actually works no
i mean it could work that way in some
cases more often
it's not quite so inaccessible you know
a great example
of this is look at how rainer maria
rilke a poet who is also interested in
the arts
was the secretary for rodin learned from
him
wrote about him um you know we could
also talk about
uh lou salome right uh and
and uh her book on nietzsche you know
nietzsche is considered to be this great
genius where do these wonderful thoughts
come from
right lou solomon tells us where some of
these wonderful thoughts come from
of course she's kind of you know should
be classified as a genius herself
so mill goes on and he says
this is not to be wonder this is too
natural to be wondered at that people
don't really care much about genius why
because it's originality that makes a
genius a genius
and he says originality is the one thing
which unoriginal minds cannot feel
the use of right originality in
thought and action so
not just originality in a narrow band
originality in the way a person lives
their life in the way that they put
it in ideas and experiences
together so what what is the value of
genius
if we backtrack a little bit in this
chapter
chapter three he says that um
originality is a valuable element in
human affairs
there's always need of persons not only
to discover new truths
and point out when what were once truths
are true no longer but to commence new
practices
i'm going to pause on that to commence
new practices
truth and originality don't play out
only in the realm of the theory or the
marketplace of ideas but also
in lifestyle also in policies also in
you know organization and he says they
set the example of more enlightened
conduct
and better taste and sense in human life
and then this allows
people to model themselves he goes on
and he says that
it's true this benefit is not capable of
being rendered by everybody alike
there are few people who actually do
this he's not saying that every person
who's deviating from customs traditions
norms
is there by a genius as a matter of fact
a lot of them are cranks
and eccentrics and you know some of them
actually may be
you know problematic in various ways but
he says
the few who do the few persons in
comparison with the whole of mankind
whose experiments if adopted by others
would be likely to be any improvement on
established practice
are the salt of the earth without them
human life
would become a stagnant pool they
introduced good things
which did not before exist it is they
who keep the life
in those which already existed and so
this is part of what geniuses
do he also talks about them being able
to
open the eyes of the unoriginal so that
they actually do have a chance
to be original themselves they can
work as a kind of model or
example or at least a catalyst to allow
people to realize that that more
is possible in the realm of music
for example eddie van halen's
tapping techniques which were not
completely original to him he learned
that
in part from other musicians but those
other musicians said wow he
went so much further than this and the
brown
sound that he generated with his
custom-made
apparatus for his amp that went on to
become
something that you could find discussed
in guitar magazine
and what was originally a million sense
genius became something that could
become a matter of technique and
technology
which then made it possible for other
people to do yet other things
within that sonic realm and we could go
on and on and on about other
examples um you know norman mailer who
one critic said had the imperialistic
pretension of like
any any form of literature he came
across he wanted to do it
a lot of his stuff are flops quite
frankly you know he is not the
uh master of all you know sort of
genres that that he aimed to be but he
did generate some good stuff in the
process which then made it possible for
other writers to come along and say i'm
going to do something
like this but but different so opening
the eyes of the unoriginal so that they
have a chance at it there are so many
people especially those in rather
deprived circumstances
for whom seeing somebody doing something
cool
became a gateway to their own
experimentation they open their mind so
geniuses do that for us it's not just
that they
write a cool poem it's that they make us
see that poetry could be a cool thing to
do
in the 21st century he goes on and he
talks about
not engaging in any sort of hero worship
which
is a debased conception of genius he
says i'm not countenancing
hero worship which applauds the strong
man of genius for forcibly seizing on
the government of the world
and making it do his bidding in spite of
himself that's that's just kind of
silliness
right dangerous silliness of course and
and degenerating and debilitating
silliness for those who
engage in it but the genius
he says can claim the freedom to point
the way the power of compelling
others into it is inconsistent with the
freedom and development of the rest but
also corrupting to the strong
person themselves but
despite that he says the initiation of
all wise or noble things
comes and must come from individuals
generally at first from some one
individual the honor and glory of the
average person is that they're capable
of following the initiative
and be led to them with his eyes open so
i may not be able to
write like roger zelazny or ursula k le
guin
but i can appreciate the genius of their
works
two authors by the way who are very open
about promoting other
authors to help them out leguin up until
you know her recent demise was doing
writing workshops
for people in which she would try to
help them out
help them on the way so geniuses are
not to be worshipped but rather to be
taken as as i mentioned catalysts
or inspiration now mill does make a few
interesting
claims a little bit earlier on about
when you can actually
have geniuses how can we
have these these people
he says that they need an atmosphere of
freedom
so he says persons of genius
are and are always likely to be a small
minority
in order to have them it's necessary to
preserve the soil in which they grow
geniuses can only breathe freely in an
atmosphere
freedom persons of genus are xv
termini more individual than any other
people less
capable consequently of fitting
themselves without hurtful compression
into any of the small number of molds
that society provides
in order to save its members the trouble
of forming their own character
this leads us to a dilemma if they
are in a rather you know traditional
even repressive society in which a lot
of options are not available
if they're too timid they will be
compressed into these molds and their
genius will not be allowed to develop
by contrast if they are particularly
vigorous and strong
they can end up becoming a target for
society
as being weird eccentric you know
outside of the norms and even being
attacked by
that very society so mill says that we
need to
have a society as much as we can
that is open to the kind of
experimentation
that would be possible and you know he
he says it's important to give the free
scope possible to uncustomary things
in order that it may in time appear
which of these are fit to be converted
into
custom so geniuses are supposed to be
accorded some special
leeway you might say but it's not
it's not all that much greater than that
accorded to other people
if we're doing what mill thinks we ought
to do
in terms of political society
and public opinion so he's arguing for
the importance and value of gene genius
and saying that we don't want to
misunderstand it and see it just
in this romantic idea of the black box
who generates this
amazing new thing and we don't know
where it's coming from instead we ought
to look at it is
genius comes from experimentation with
life
and from a robust marketplace of ideas
and lifestyles
you